One benefit of cloud computing
is that it empowers anyone
to porpetually have infinite resources.
As long as you can pay, you can have
the resources that are required to work
on maybe hard problems that
involve lots of data and
that require lots of processing.
Here are some illustrations that
I've found pretty informative.
To illustrate how much of
data are we dealing with in
terms of our everyday life in our world.
So if we just think about one year,
2011, there
were 1.8 zettabytes of data that
were created in that one year.
This amount of data is
equivalent to everyone
in the US tweeting 4,320 times a day.
Pretty much not doing much else.
Or another way to think about
it's this amount of data
is 200 billion high definition movies
that are each about two hours long.
If you lived for
47 million years, you'd be just about
done watching these 200 billion movies.
Or to store this much data,
it would require so
many of the Apple's 32 gigabit iPads,
that if you stack them
up together, it would be 25
times higher than Mt Fiji.
Pretty powerful these illustrations.
And this is all the data from 2011 only.
Clearly not every application
needs access to all of the data
that's generated that's
available in the world.
But a lot of the applications for
scientific discovery,
for improving social services, for
a number of other types of applications,
they do require a lot data.
Looking at cloud computing
as a big data engine,
there are a number of layers
that are necessary in order for
the cloud to provide that
kind of infrastructure and
adopt those kinds of services that are
needed by these big data applications.
Cloud platforms that offer as
a platform as a service stack for
big data processing.
At the minimum have to have some
layer that enables the storage and
access of the data from cross many,
many nodes.
And also the ability to describe
applications in a certain
parallel fashion, and
ideally to do that easily, so
that the data can be processed
across potentially many nodes.
We talked earlier in this course
that access to memory and
access to local memory is
faster than going to disk.
And particularly if you
have to go to disk that
need these nodes that's
attached to another node.
So most of the cloud stacks also
incorporate some data caching
layer where the data can
be brought in memory, or
maybe even a cross multiple memories, in
the distributed system, big data system.
I said a cloud platform for
big data must incorporate some
data processing framework.
But commonly, when we talk
about small or smaller data,
the way we are analyzing it is
using things like SQL queries or
some other type of querying mechanism.
And so often cloud stack, big data
stacks, would incorporate some language
front end that would make this data
processing a little bit more easier.
One common thing that people do with
big data, that they analyze it.
They search for certain patterns, so
they perform some data mining operations
that often involved common functions,
such as some machine
learning algorithms.
So just as it's common for
cloud big data platforms to support
popular language front-ends,
it's also common for them to support
popular analytics libraries.
And also, a lot of the types of
data that we're interested in
isn't just created once, and then
that's it, that's a complete data set.
Instead, there's continuously
generated knowledge.
And then potentially,
the answers from the analysis on that
knowledge are derived continuously and
updated over time.
So therefore, a common service
that needs to be incorporated
in big data clouds would be something
that provides as streaming abilities,
both as inputs and as outputs.